[Musik]
halb europa öffnet aber deutschland bei
uns bleibt weiter alles dicht und immer
mehr menschen fragen warum ist das so
wir haben hier am wochenende tausende
menschen bei protesten in berlin gesehen
meist ohne abstand aber die
außengastronomie wo es kaffee gibt wo es
bier gibt all das bleibt weiter verboten
was macht das mit dem coroner land
deutschland und was macht das mit den
menschen und über diese fragen möchte
ich sprechen mit meinen gästen mit dem
spd chef norbert walter borjans mit dem
csu generalsekretär markus blume mit fdp
chef christian lindner und dem
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen michael
kellner schönen guten abend ich möchte
ihn einmal bilder zeigen von gestern
abend hier in berlin gestern nachmittag
zehntausende menschen auf den straßen
bei den traditionellen mai demos ist gab
dort auch gewalt aber vor allem war zu
sehen dass viele menschen an einem ort
waren und da war wenig abstand zu halten
wir haben das zusammengefasst morgen bei
uns bei bild auf der seite drei mit der
frage tausende bei demos aber wir dürfen
draußen kein bier trinken
herr walter borjans können sie das
unseren lesern erklären
ja ich kann erst mal erklären dass
tausende bei demos ohne abstand und
maske ohne die hygiene regeln die
einzuhalten sind nicht geht und dass
wenn sich diejenigen die an
demonstrationen in dieser weise
teilnehmen
dann müssen sie damit rechnen dass die
polizei die demonstration auflösen und
das hat sie ja da auch getan
bei der letzten demo wo das der fall war
nämlich bei den querdenkern da hat sich
ihre co vorsitzende saskia esken relativ
prominente zu wort gemeldet bei twitter
ich würde ihnen einmal noch den tweet
zeigen da hat sie gesagt tausende co wie
die otn feiern sich in berlin als die
zweite welle ohne abstand ohne maske sie
gefährden damit nicht nur unsere
gesundheit sie gefährden unsere erfolge
gegen die pandemie
für die belebung von wirtschaft bildung
und gesellschaft und verantwortlich
heute und gestern mehr walter borjans
hat sie sich nicht geäußert die spd ist
da sehr ruhig geht da nicht das gleiche
wie bei den provisionen sowie das gästen
ist ausdrückt doch es gilt ganz klar wir
haben aber auch oder sachsen hat nach
dem damaligen gibt ja auch eine ganze
reihe von diskussionen geführt über
diese bezeichnung und daraus ihre
schlüsse auch gezogen
das hat aber an der haltung dazu
überhaupt nichts geändert
egal ob es querdenker sind oder ob es
chaoten sind wie wir das gestern in
berlin erlebt haben
es ist nicht zulässig und vor allen
dingen wir werden mit allen kräften
dagegen setzen wir müssen das
demonstrations- die
demonstrationsfreiheit sichern
das versammlungsrecht ist ein ganz
wichtiges gut in einer demokratie aber
wer das missbraucht und wer sich nicht
an die regeln hält muss egal von welcher
seite er demonstriert damit rechnen dass
er bestraft wird beziehungsweise dass
die demonstration aufgelöst wird
unabhängig von der gewalt und der frage
wie die spd darauf reagiert ämter
borjans auch wenn sie draußen sind in
diesen tagen und sehen was in der stadt
los ist wenn man dann diese
demonstration sieht da haben doch die
bürger einfach kein verständnis mehr
dafür dass es nicht erlaubt sein soll in
der außengastronomie mit abstand
zusammenzusitzen und mal ein bier zu
trinken was ist denn ihre antwort darauf
die antwort ist noch mal darauf wir
können nicht diejenigen die sich nicht
an regeln halten zum maßstab dafür
machen wie wir insgesamt gegen diese
pandemie vorgehen ich glaube dass wir im
augenblick auf einem guten weg sind wir
haben selbst kritisiert wie das impf und
das testmanagement angelaufen ist
insofern wäre mir selbst lieber gewesen
wir wären mit dem fortschritt weiter
jetzt sind wir bei einer zahl von rund
einer million pro tag
und wenn wir an dieser stelle aufgeben
würden
und da reden wir eben nicht von einem
teil
an einem tag in einer stadt sondern
wirklich bundesweit wie wir mit dieser
frage umgehen dann würden wir einen
fehler machen deswegen haben sich alle
beteiligten jahr zusammengesetzt wir
haben mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz
eine bundesweite regelung für eine
bestimmte instanz rate nämlich über 100
festgelegt und ich glaube diese strecke
die sollten wir jetzt noch gemeinsam
durchstehen und glauben sie mir ich
gehöre auch nicht zu denen die glücklich
damit sind dass sie nicht auf die straße
können dass sie nicht in die
außengastronomie können
ich habe auch einen straße hören sie ja
schon denn wir haben zum beispiel ihren
parteivorsitzenden auch andere bei der
spd bei den demonstrationen gesehen auch
umringt von vielen menschen aber dennoch
herr blume für sie in bayern sicherlich
auch nicht ganz leicht den menschen zu
erklären wie das sein kann also dass
weiterhin der biergarten dicht bleibt
dass man sich nicht mal ins café setzen
darf wie soll das noch logisch sein was
da passiert hier in unserem land also
zunächst mal dass die biergärten noch
nicht öffnen können ist natürlich den
chor oder umständen geschuldet und
deswegen habe ich auf der anderen seite
umso weniger verständnis um genauer zu
sein
null verständnis dass gerade auch in
corona zeiten oder trotz corona zeiten
sich die linksradikalen chaoten in
berlin nicht aufhalten lassen und wie
jedes jahr dort randale machen ich würde
mir wünschen wenn es hier von
politischer seite von links nicht
sprachlosigkeit gelbe sondern eine klare
absage und eine klare verurteilung
dessen was dort passiert erstens diese
randale gewalt gegenüber der polizei ist
zutiefst zu verurteilen aber zweitens
auch dass dort einfach alle chor ohne
regeln nicht eingehalten werden
da darf nie der eindruck entstehen dass
hier mit zweierlei maß gemessen wurde je
nachdem wer da gerade marschiert mit
zweierlei maß wie bewerten sie das sie
sind wohnhaft in der uckermark aber
natürlich als bundesgeschäftsführer viel
in berlin wie haben sie diese mai demos
gesehen und gibt es da so eine doppel
doppelte sicht auf die dinge dass auch
aus ihrer partei und von der spd
bei den querdenkern das eben scharf
kritisiert wurde und jetzt herr kerner
plötzlich
ja ein bisschen sprachlosigkeit herrscht
gar nicht wir haben sehr deutlich die
gewalt verurteilt ich weiß auch nicht
was mit dem ersten mal zu tun haben soll
menschen anzugreifen polizisten
anzugreifen oder barrikaden zu errichten
das verurteilen wir vorteile ich klar
und deutlich und zugleich haben wir
gesehen dass am ersten mai ja viele
menschen ganz corona konform mit masken
dafür demonstriert haben dafür
kundgebungen macht haben dass wir
bessere arbeitsbedingungen im land haben
das ist auch legitim und da ist auch
versammlungsfreiheit
demonstrationsfreiheit ein hoher wert
dann haben in den letzten monaten immer
verteidigt egal von welchen seiten aber
auflagen müssen gelten und die müssen
eingehalten werden egal wie nah oder
fern man meint stimmten demonstrationen
zu stehen herr lindner sie fühlen sie
fordern schon seit wochen seit monaten
dass die außengastronomie geöffnet
werden soll wie haben sie das wochenende
in berlin verbracht haben sich getraut
in richtung der demo mal zu schauen was
möglich ist in dieser zeit
nein ich habe nicht mit demonstriert
allerdings den polizei-einsatz
registriert auch hier wo ich hier im
westen von berlin lebe war das spürbar
da fragt man sich schon ob das in diesem
jahr in der pandemie situation
eigentlich richtiger kräfteeinsatz ist
oder ob man nicht anders auch für
arbeitsbedingungen und seine politischen
inhalte demonstrieren kann aber gut das
demonstrationsrecht muss gesichert sein
ich werd schätze dass herr walter
borjans und herr keller sich hier sehr
klar distanziert haben das gehört auch
zur politischen auseinandersetzung dazu
dass man das anerkennt übrigens wünsche
ich mir die gleiche klarheit von beiden
auch bei den gewalttätigen übergriffen
zb auch cdu politiker die sich gegen den
mieten deckel ausgesprochen und geklagt
haben dort gab es ja auch vandalismus
und gewalttätige übergriffe
ich habe das bei herrn lauterbach dessen
meinungen ich nicht teile immer auch
kritisiert dass gewalt nie eine
auseinandersetzung im politischen
gespräch sein kann bei mieten deckel
muss das in gleicher weise von der
anderen seite auch gelten in der sache
gilt wenn die instanzen es zulassen wenn
das pandemie geschehen es zulässt dann
muss auch mehr gesellschaftliches leben
möglich sein und das ist es auch nicht
an jeder stelle aber an vielen stellen
im land und deshalb ist die fokussierung
nur alleine auf die hunderter infektions
zahl falsch wenn man sich nur auf die
infektionszahlen und nicht auf das
gesamte pandemie geschehen konzentriert
dann könnten in deutschland bis zu den
sommerferien keine schulen öffnen ich
glaube das würden wir alle als inhuman
begreifen wir möchten mal einen mit in
die runde nehmen der ganz persönlich
betroffen ist von der situation und auch
am wochenende natürlich gesehen hat was
in berlin los war selbst gastwirt ist
moritz ludolf ist uns zugeschaltet herr
ludorf wenn sie die bilder sehen von den
protestmärschen hier in berlin
von denjenigen die da wenig abstand
halten und dann gleichzeitig erleben
müssen dass sie seit monaten weiterhin
nicht öffnen können nicht öffnen dürfen
und ihnen das ja immer wieder auch von
der politik gesagt wird was geht ihnen
da durch den kopf
ja das ist sehr schwer zu verarbeiten
also ich teile die meinung dass wir auch
das demonstrationsrecht sicherlich waren
müssen also auch die möglichkeit dazu
weiterhin geben müssen wie das ganze
vonstatten geht ist natürlich nicht
wirklich zu tolerieren
aber gerade vor dem hintergrund jetzt
unsere geschlossen außengastronomie zu
sehen dass das nicht möglich ist es für
mich für meine mitarbeiter und auch für
unsere gäste mehr als schwer zu
begreifen die fragen kommen tatsächlich
täglich immer wieder auf ich kann sie
nicht mehr beantworten
sie können die fragen nicht beantworten
gleichzeitig erzählen sie uns was
bedeutet dass mittlerweile für ihren
auch finanziellen verlust haben sie die
hilfen bekommen die angekündigt waren
mittlerweile und wie sieht es jetzt für
die nächsten wochen und die nächsten
monate aus ja das ist doch sicherlich
zweigeteilter die hilfen sind in jedem
fall angekommen die hilfen sind auch
richtig aber wir müssen ja inzwischen
auch mal über alternativen nachdenken
alternativen sind die öffnung das heißt
die hilfen helfen uns unsere unternehmen
werden dass corinna bedingt sicherlich
überstehen da bin ich guter dinge auch
bei vielen kollegen
wir haben aber sicherlich ganz andere
probleme problem nummer eins ist unsere
mitarbeiter sind inzwischen weg gelaufen
also auch bei uns sind viele leute nicht
mehr da die kommen auch nicht mehr
zurück in unsere brauchen
ich hab halt gar keine möglichkeiten
mehr wenn corona irgendwann mal vorbei
ist die leute wieder ganz normal zu
bewirtschaften das wird ein riesengroßes
problem bei uns sein und problem nummer
zwei ist wir sind zum beispiel ein
betrieb der sich jetzt sehr stark darauf
eingestellt hatten außer haus geschäft
tätig zu werden da gibt es ja
verschiedene staffelungen der
hilfsgelder und bei uns ist zb der fall
wir haben einen gewissen staffel
erreicht wo wir nicht mehr die vollen
hilfen wo es nicht mehr die vollen
hilfen zu stehen und wir stehen am ende
des monats oder am ende dieser dieser
sechsmonatsfrist dieses jahres mit
demselben ergebnis da sind zugelassen
hätten
das bedeutet für uns es werden
diejenigen bestraft die am ende auch
noch arbeiten und wirklich versuchen das
bestmögliche rauszuholen wir haben
aktuell viele viele kollegen die sagen
mehr als 30 prozent um dann brauche ich
gar nicht machen obwohl ich es könnte
aber damit mache ich mir mal den ganzen
höchsten kaputt er weiter bei uns wenn
sie das hören bestrafen sie mit ihren
gesetzen jetzt auch mit dem bundes
lockdown diejenigen die eigentlich noch
arbeiten wollen dann wirklich trafen
sicher niemanden und ich will nur
nochmals sagen dass wir in deutschland
bei aller problemstellungen die wir
haben und ich weiß wie schwer das gerade
für gastronomie für einzelhandel in
unseren innenstädten ist sie das für
kulturbetriebe veranstaltungs betriebe
ist ist das eine extreme belastung aber
wir haben in deutschland so viele
wirtschaftshilfen mobilisiert wie die
gesamte restliche europäische union
zusammen
das heißt also da war die menschen
wollen jetzt ja nur über hilfe reden
sondern endlich wieder arbeiten sie
sagen sie da sagt ja wir natürlich dass
er gar nicht weiß wie er wieder anfangen
soll wenn die menschen den weg laufen
sie haben noch mit mir niemanden vor
sich den dem das gefällt oder vor sich
sitzen
wer dem das gefällt das hier betriebe
nicht arbeiten können
wir haben doch abzuwägen und wir sehen
doch im augenblick oder wir haben gerade
noch vor wenigen tagen gesehen wie die
infektionsraten in die höhe geschossen
sind wir haben jetzt mit dem was wir
haben offenbar mindestens schon mal
einen stillstand und in dem maße in dem
jetzt der im fortschritt kommt sehen wir
dass die zahlen langsam herunter gehen
können
das ist eine zumutung für alle das ist
überhaupt keine frage aber es ist keine
strafe für jemanden und ich will nur
noch mal sagen weil sie es ebenso in den
vergleich
mit demonstrationen gesetzt haben werden
in berlin 40 demonstrationen von den 39
friedlich verlaufen sind
ich kann nicht 39 demonstrationen
verbieten mit dem hinweis darauf dass es
chaoten gibt und das sage ich nochmal
die bestraft werden müssen die sich
daran nicht halten und das gilt im
übrigen auch deshalb berlin na ja zu
recht gesagt das gilt auch für jede form
von drohungen von hetze und zwar egal
gegen wen und von wem das macht keinen
unterschied das sind alles formen der
auseinandersetzung die in stück platz
gegriffen haben in den letzten monaten
die absolut nicht tolerierbar sind
er wolle jetzt weiß ich es angesprochen
haben die frage ist ganz kurz herr
walter borjans ihr vize kevin kühnert
hat vor dem cdu bundestagsabgeordneten
der sich eingesetzt hat gegen die
mietpreis bremse gegen den mieten decke
hat demonstriert und merkwürdige dinge
skandiert und im hintergrund waren noch
die farbbeutel anschläge zu sehen wie
sehen sie das
also demonstrieren ist was anderes als
gewalt gutheißen drohungen gutheißen das
darf nicht der fall sein ich kann mit
kinder die badegäste nicht vor einem
weit will es ist klar das ist eine dass
es eine tolerierung von gewalt egal und
auch nicht drohungen nicht nur gewalt
sondern auch drohungen ich weiß welche
belastung unter anderem das circa
lauterbach bedeutet mit dem ich mich da
ständig darüber unterhalte und das gilt
für mitglieder der cdu oder der fdp der
grünen und andere ganz genauso es ist
nicht zu akzeptieren und dazu stehe ich
abseits der proteste erweiterbar lindner
beschäftigt die menschen auch die frage
unter welchen hintergrund vor welchem
hintergrund dieser bundes lockdown
tatsächlich passiert ist
bei der bahn siemens angesprochen die
zahlen sind stabilisiert aber alle
experten sagen das kann zeitlich nicht
mit der entscheidung im bundestag zu tun
haben sondern die experten sind sich
einig dass sozusagen diese dritte welle
schon früher gebrochen wurde und ich
möchte ihnen dazu einmal eine statistik
eine prognose des rk ii zeigen die
sozusagen zu ostern die rote kurve ist
das was das r
prognostiziert hat und da sehen wir wie
die kurve dann tatsächlich verlaufen ist
und sie ist es auch weiterhin in eine
richtung verlaufen die die eben nicht
diese große alarm zahlen ja dann am ende
gegeben hat herr blume haben sie da zu
viel panik gemacht
nein ganz im gegenteil ich denke das was
wir hier sehen
und was wir zum glück im moment auch
erleben dass wir einen der vielleicht
sogar trendbruch haben bei der zunahme
der infektionen bei der entwicklung der
inzidenz das ist darauf zurückzuführen
dass wir natürlich nach wie vor mit viel
konsequenz unterwegs sind
es ist ja nicht so dass jetzt plötzlich
mit dem bundesgesetz dann etwas ganz
neues sind inländer passiert ist bayern
das war ja dass die begründung von eine
andere
nein das war eine anfangs so dramatisch
werden dass man jetzt was tun muss das
war die begründung sozusagen dem
bundesland zu machen da können sie jetzt
ja nicht sagen das hat damit nichts zu
tun
nein aber der punkt war doch ein anderer
wir wollten dass überall und zwar ohne
zu zögern dann bestimmte maßnahmen
greifen
in bayern hat sich mit dem bundesgesetz
nicht viel geändert
bei uns sind im wesentlichen die meisten
regelungen kraft geblieben und natürlich
ich meinte das wäre ja schlimm wenn das
was an beschränkungen nach wie vor da
ist einfach distanz unterricht an den
schulen
der einzelhandel mit ganz großen
einschränkungen viele gesellschaftliche
bereiche des öffentlichen lebens sind
nach wie vor lahmgelegt es wäre eine
katastrophe wenn das keine wirkung
zeigen würde
deswegen sage ich ihnen heute abend zum
glück und das ist für mich ein echtes
hoffnungszeichen
zum glück gehen die inzidenz jetzt
langsam rückwärts und zum zweiten
bekommen wir wirklich ordentlich schwung
gibt es beim thema impfen rein
das wird sich auszahlen und deswegen bin
ich froh dass wir jetzt in der kommenden
woche endlich darüber ist dass wir
endlich darüber reden ja das ist er noch
einen wir auch normalität deswegen wir
müssen auch kritisch darüber sprechen
unter welchen voraussetzungen bestimmte
entscheidung getroffen wurde
walter borjans wenn sie diese m
prognosen sehen
die ist dort gegeben hat wenn sie sehen
was auch andere wissenschaftler gesagt
haben in den vergangenen wochen in den
vergangenen monaten welche horrorzahlen
wir erleben und wie dann entschieden
wurde
hat man da auf die falschen experten
gesetz erst mal weiß man nicht im
vorhinein welcher experte welche
prognose macht ich kann nur sagen dass
die experten gerade in dieser pandemie
extrem genaue prognosen gemacht haben
und wenn etwas besser läuft als
befürchtet dann bin ich immer sehr froh
darüber
ich will einmal einen beispielen denn
sie kennen alle das beispiel dass der
saarländische ministerpräsident tobias
hans sein land zu einem modellprojekt
ausgerufen hat und eben meinte mit
niedrigen incidents raten ein modell
fahren zu können mehr öffnung fahren zu
können
das ergebnis ist dass sich da die
incident verdoppelt hat und jetzt bei
rund 540 legt also es ist doch nichts
gebäudetypen kommende und wirkungslos
bitte herr blume hat immer wenn sie über
tübingen gesprochen aber die frage geht
weiter an an händler herr lindner wurde
hier mit experten eine ja panik
verbreitet und dann eine entscheidung
getroffen wenn wir jetzt diese zahlen
uns betrachten nein das möchte ich
nichts sagen herbolzheimer ich glaube
nicht dass bei der festlegung einer
incidents von 565 in einer nachtsitzung
dass bei dieser zahl irgendein experte
dabei gewesen ist das war einfach besser
also da möchte ich gerne wissen welche
experten sollen da dabei gewesen sein zu
sagen es soll genau 165 er incident
seien für die schulschließung kann man
doch kein erklärt ich möchte ja nach
vorne schauen möchte feststellen dass
heute abend der spd ministerpräsident
von niedersachsen sagt es braucht test
basierte öffnungs konzepte zum beispiel
für die gastronomie hat er recht warum
ich fast bei der bundes notbremse
abgesagt worden
die das bayerische landeskabinett hat am
17 april noch herr blume am 17 ab
kurz vor der bundesrat beschlossen das
bis einer 200h incidents auch noch click
and collect mit click und nicht sogar
möglich sein soll also handel mit
terminvereinbarung auf basis bei test
jetzt plötzlich kann es ihnen gar nicht
scharf genug sein am siebten april haben
sie etwas ganz anderes in ihrem landes
kabinett beschlossen und heimlich still
und leise und ein argument wurde das
dann durch die bundes notbremse im
ersetzt will damit zum ausdruck bringen
eigentlich müsste uns doch allen daran
gelegen sein den gesundheitsschutz mit
gesellschaftlichen leben zu vereinbaren
und das ist möglich mit den
abstandsregeln und einer konsequent
durchgesetzten masken pflicht mit
beschleunigung beim impfen freundliche
grüße benutzen immer noch nicht alle im
free serben immer noch setzen der auf
die impfzentren statt auf den
niedergelassenen bereich dadurch dass
wir erreichen mit hygiene konzepten und
luft filtern zum beispiel
außengastronomie und handel zu
ermöglichen das ist möglich und
verabschieden der uns bitte von der
hunderter inzidenz oder der 165 er
allein die sag doch gar nicht genug aus
derweil hat heute abend zu treffen es
dazu gesagt wir möchten einmal auf
andere länder in europa schauen denn ich
habe es am anfang erwähnt
dort sieht diese situation völlig anders
aus europa lockert freiheit statt
lockdown unsere nachbarn werfen die
korona ketten up lite denn in
deutschland gibt es keine perspektive
keine hoffnung auflockerungen und das
obwohl unser incidence wert niedrig ist
in italien kehrt das dolce vita zurück
gäste dürfen zurück in restaurants und
bars selbst open airs und kinos starten
wieder durch und das bei einer inzidenz
von 152
davon können die deutschen nur träumen
die inzidenz liegt hier aktuell bei über
160 heißt lehre bars und lehrer
restaurants dauer lockdown sogar
ausgangssperren fakt ist unsere
europäischen nachbarn öffnen und das mit
wesentlich höheren inzidenz werden ein
leben in freiheit für die briten schon
lange normalität heinz im parkfest all
das geht wieder die straßen sind voll
na dann tschüss und so wird es bald auch
in den niederlanden aussehen mittwoch
öffnen dort geschäfte und cafés und das
bei einer instanz von 331 wie sieht es
denn in frankreich aus die dance 305
meter kabel selbst die locken seit
montag sind grundschulen wieder offen
präsenzunterricht trotz lockdown davon
können die kleinsten deutschen träume
träumen können wir auch von österreich
am 19 meister praktisch alles wieder
offen tourismus kultur in der sport
theater und konzerte incidents 170 höher
als in deutschland soll darauf
vielleicht nur so apropos wie sieht's
denn in griechenland aus da geht der
tourismus am 14 mai wieder los blume
wenn sie diese bilder sehen sie sind mit
dafür verantwortlich mit ihrem harten
kurs dass wir in deutschland die letzten
sind die wahrheit ist herr uns haben wir
in dem vergleich den sie jetzt gerade
angestellt haben
da muss man ehrlicherweise sagen sind
wir nicht schlecht gefahren mangelnde
konsequenz in europa ist immer wieder
bestraft worden und die länder die sie
jetzt gerade hier raus gegriffen haben
frankreich italien österreich wir haben
ja mehrmals eine schaukel locker und
hingelegt kurz für ein paar tage
geöffnet und dann einen locker und sehr
viel härter war als der in deutschland
da war glaube ich der kurs den wir
gefahren sind
unter dem strich der bessere und wir
haben unser gesundheitssystem auch nicht
so an die belastungsgrenze gebracht oder
über die belastungsgrenze geführt wie
das zum beispiel in frankreich in den
letzten wochen der fall war
für mich ist etwas anderes entscheiden
und da darf ich anknüpfen bei dem was
christian lindner gerade gesagt hat wir
müssen schauen dass wir jetzt den hebel
umlegen wie gesagt die explosionsartige
steigerung der inzidenz der infektionen
haben wir
wie es aussieht im moment besser im
griff und gleichzeitig wächst die
möglichkeit mit den durch impfen oder
das heißt christian lindner hat gerade
von einer textbasierten öffnungs
strategie gesprochen ich würde das gerne
ergänzen um eine impf basierte
lockerungs strategie das ist das was wir
jetzt in der kommenden woche machen
müssen dass wir so schnell wie möglich
grundrechts normalität herstellen heißt
auf gut deutsch
für diejenigen die geimpft sind dass
dann der zugang zu kultur zu allen
möglichen angeboten auch zum reisen
wieder einfacher wird ist das dann der
ball ist rund was lange vermisst haben
im pass vors restaurant gehen oder muss
ich dann mit dem impfpass immer reisen
wie wird das ganze technisch abläufen
für diejenigen die geimpft sind
also wenn wir schon ein bisschen weiter
wären dann glaube ich wäre das alles
digital abgebildet dann hätten wir auch
diesen europäischen impfpass als die
digitalen impfpass und warum haben
ich glaube da haben wir alle dieselbe
feststellung dass das genau der bereich
ist kollektiv in deutschland wo wir uns
alle miteinander die auch heute hier
versammelt sind einfach mehr aufbruch
mehr flexibilität wünschen
man muss allerdings auch sagen da
spreche ich jetzt walter borjans an als
in der letzten runde der
ministerpräsidenten darüber gesprochen
wurde ob wir in denen er doppelt
geimpften mehr möglichkeiten geben sie
zumindest gleich stellen mit getesteten
das gerade von den
spd-ministerpräsidenten massiv gebremst
worden
ich bin froh dass es jetzt so aussieht
als wenn wir in der kommenden woche
deutlich weiter kommen könnten aber ich
möchte trotzdem nochmal wissen bevor er
walter borjans antworten kann der blume
wer ist daran schuld dass wir auch da
wieder versagt haben dass wir es nicht
hinbekommen haben ab dem zeitpunkt wo
klar war dass sind impfstoff gibt da
etwas zu entwickeln was dann auch
wirklich da ist weil man muss sich das
einmal vorstellen das ist ja wahnsinn
also es gibt schon mehrere millionen
dämpfte die haben jetzt diesen gelben
pass wie die das dann sozusagen
technisch anwenden können das völlig
offen und völlig unten unklar ist auch
wie das ganze dann in einem digitalen
impfpass münden soll also das ist doch
der wahnsinn dass wir das auch nicht
hinbekommen haben
solange wir nichts besseres haben ist es
der gelbe impfpass aber natürlich haben
sie recht
das muss digital sein und wahrscheinlich
stellen wir uns damit deutscher
gründlichkeit immer wieder selbst ein
bein weil wir die allerbeste die aller
sicherste lösung haben wollen und die
allerbeste und die aller sicherste das
ist halt die da auch am aller längsten
dauert war der digitalisierung ist aber
leider auch geschwindigkeit trumpf und
deswegen wünsche ich mir dass wir sowohl
in deutschland wie auch in europa jetzt
hier schnell was auf die beine stellen
können herr keller wer ist daran schuld
dass wir auch beim digitalen im pass
wieder hinten dran sind dass das erst im
juni da sein sollen also schon mit dem
impfstoff hat es nicht richtig geklappt
wir kriegen das nicht hin dass die
zahlen der infektion pünktlich da sind
wir kriegen es jetzt auch wieder mit dem
digitalen impfpass nicht hin wer ist
daran schuld
nur ein bisschen landrut zu lange auf
faxgeräte gesetzt statt auch eine
digitalisierung voranzubringen habe ich
will gar nicht hier einfach
schuldzuweisung verteilen mein gott da
verteilt sich die verteilt sieht
verantwortung glaube ziemlich breit aber
wir reden ja aber gerade was kann eine
perspektive sein und in der tat wollen
wir nicht dass wir in den nächsten
touchdown und durch zu schnelles öffnen
rein ja ich bin auch der meinung wir
müssen grundrechte menschen zurückgeben
das ist nichts was man vorenthalten kann
und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht wenn
man noch immer da raushalten hang gehört
die bewohnerinnen und bewohner dürfen
nicht zusammen essen ja also was soll
das das finde ich dann meinen dass es
geht nicht oder dass die geimpften
angehörigen in den kliniken die
krankenschwestern die pfleger nicht
zusammen eine pause machen können sodann
david aberwitzig dass du es schnell vom
tisch
das dann muss steiner regeln her und
dann glaube ich dass wir jetzt mit
hochdruck weiter impfen müssen
das ist zum glück zum glück hat sich die
geschwindigkeit erhöht so dass wir noch
eine weile durchhalten so dass allen
menschen hilfe angeboten können und dass
das eine gute möglichkeit dann ist auch
weiter zu öffnen sodass der länder auch
machen
ich stelle geimpft haben als wir und
dann würde ich mir auch wünschen dass
sondern umfasst natürlich elektronisch
funktioniert und nicht per fax gerät und
papierauswahl erweiterbar eines m was
ist ihre vorstellung davon nächste woche
sondern das ganze beschlossen werde
für die geimpften die chinesen welche
rechte habe ich wenn ich geimpft bin was
kann ich dann tun und wie wir das ganze
dann umgesetzt mit welchen pass muss
sich wohin gehen ich würde gerne weil
sie es eben schon mal angekündigt haben
dass ich noch einmal reagieren kann nur
eines vorweg sagen und zwar also der ein
spieler den sie eben gezeigt haben er
hat mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
irritiert
es kann doch nicht sein dass wir hier
ein wettlauf machen wer macht schon bei
300 auf wehrmacht bei 200 auf und wir
machen erst bei 100 auf also ich möchte
wirklich oder kann ich an blumen nur
recht geben sagen ich möchte mit denen
die sich jetzt freuen dass sie ihre
freiheiten zurück erlangen nicht in
jedem punkt tauschen
ich glaube dass das was wir insgesamt
erlebt haben ich weiß dass man nicht mit
opferzahlen vergleichen argumentieren
darf aber ich möchte wissen was wäre
wenn bei uns der verlauf der pandemie so
gewesen wäre wie im vereinigten
königreich was dann hier in den
zeitungen stunde
aber da kann ich nur sagen ich glaube
dass wir da einiges falsch aber auch
eine menge rief aber aber es gibt nun
eben auch viele länder wo man ganz klar
nachvollziehen kann zb die schweiz
teilweise österreich und andere länder
die sozusagen ähnliche ähnliche
infektionszahlen hatten dann haben wir
dicht gemacht und die haben teilweise
offen gelassen und da ist die kurve
gleich geblieben also so einfach es ist
auch nicht dabei war und dass man sage
ich ganz nur ich kann nur sei es in der
schweiz auch zu zeiten ganz anders
gewesen ist also was ich jetzt nur sagen
will ist christine lambrecht die
justizministerin bereitet eine
verordnung vorbereitet klare regeln vor
die in der nächsten woche im kabinett
von bastian regeln das waren die
menschen doch jetzt nichts soll da
passieren also was beispielsweise dazu
gehören muss ist dass jemand der die
vollständige impfung hat dann natürlich
nicht mehr von einer ausgangssperre
unterworfen ist und dass er aber weiter
auch mit hygiene regeln also maske und
abstand halten
ohne einen test nachweis in ein geschäft
gehen kann das sind die ersten punkte
und wir kommen hoffentlich bald weiter
weil einfach auch die zahl der geimpften
größer geworden ist also eines muss ich
dann meinen gelben im fast immer dabei
haben wir leicht wenn ich raus will
weiter bei uns also nehmen wir an sie
haben das ja ebene angesprochen im
moment ist es so dass sie nach weiß
brauchen wir haben leider den nachweis
auf elektronischem weg nicht herr blume
hat glaube ich durch die blume
angedeutet wo das defizit im
wesentlichen sitzt also nach 22 uhr geld
machen würde wäre es wieder wäre es
wieder hinab koalitionäre opposition ja
wir haben im bereich des
gesundheitsministeriums sowohl was die
weiterentwicklung der app kann gingen
auch was die elektronische erfassung
jetzt an geht aber auch was testen und
impfen angeht zeit verloren das hätte
schneller gehen können aber da sollten
wir jetzt auch nicht nach hinten gucken
sondern sagen wir sind jetzt auf dem weg
indem wir nach und nach diese
freiheitsrechte zurechtgerückt werden
können
und ich glaube dass wir alle chancen
haben am ende sagen zu können dass wir
verhältnismäßig bei all dem was ja aber
ich möchte jetzt trotzdem noch mal wurde
walter borjans das ist mir wichtig
gerade durch den riesigen menschen
müssen möchten das ja verstehen also ist
jetzt meine große freiheit wenn ich
geimpft bin dass ich mit meinem gelben
pass auch nach 22 uhr oder dann
mitternacht vor die tür darf ist dass
die große rückgabe der freiheitsrechte
ja wir haben zuerst mal es geht ja
einmal erstmal um die freiheitsrechte
nämlich dass jemand der geimpft ist und
dies nachweisen kann das ist im
augenblick nur der gelbe impfpass dass
der das was ansonsten bisher mit einem
test belegt werden musste natürlich in
anspruch nehmen kann und die zahlen ab
wo wieder etwas geöffnet werden kann
die sind ja nicht teil dieser verordnung
das machen die länder und insofern muss
ich auch nochmal an die adresse von
herrn lindner sagen ja nur 165 ist
natürlich eine
nicht aus irgendeiner wissenschaftlichen
forschung sich ergebende zahl es ist ja
auch nicht die zahl die entscheidet wo
eine schule auf macht oder nicht es ist
die zahl von wo an der bund ist in die
hand nimmt die länder haben die
möglichkeiten darunter andere regeln
fest und härtere regeln festzulegen und
wenn sie sich mal angucken wie viele
menschen sich doch jetzt im augenblick
auch darüber beklagen dass es keinen
kompletten lockdown gibt dass wir nicht
weiter runter fahren dann kann man doch
nicht einfach so tun als wenn alle zu
hause setzen und sagen würden warum
dürfen eigentlich ist das in ihrem
umfeld sei der bau an sich dass die
menschen zu ihnen sagen sie sollen noch
härter zu greifen und noch noch härteren
lockt doch gar nicht nein die menschen
ich erlebe dass wir als politiker alle
gemeinsam im übrigen das ist jetzt gar
keine frage einer einzelnen partei
abzuwenden haben zwischen enormen
unterschiedlichen sichtweisen erstens
der menschen im land aber auch der
unterschiedlichen wissenschaftsdisziplin
disziplinen die medizin sagt uns ganz
klar ihr müsst noko fit machen ihr müsst
weiter runter gehen und wir haben aber
auf der anderen seite auch pädagogik wir
haben psychologie wir haben
wirtschaftsergebnisse
wirtschaftswissenschaftliche ergebnisse
die uns zeigen was es alles an folgen
gibt die sich einstellen wenn wir einen
kompletten lockdown haben und dann ist
es so dass wenn sie einen
abwägungsprozess haben dass sie sich
kritik aussetzen die müssen wir
aushalten
ich glaube dass wir aber trotzdem auf
einem weg sind der in wenigen wochen
oder monaten
ich würde wirklich sagen im sommer ganz
anders aussieht aber sie wissen doch
auch dass wir nicht wissen was ist mit
neu auftretenden mutanten was ist mit
möglichen impfstoff lieferungen über die
wir nicht herr sind sondern die bei
einzelnen unternehmen liegen ich gehe
davon aus dass das gut geht ich glaube
da gibt es gute zeichen für die ich
verstehe aber auch dass sie menschen
zweifeln und sagen wir haben schon
einiges gesehen was jetzt nicht
funktioniert hat wir warten mal ab und
gucken muss das an der lindner glauben
sie dass das funktionieren wird mit
einem impfpass dann vor die tür zu gehen
und zu sagen zumindest darf ich jetzt
nach mitternacht wieder raus ist das
genug wenn man sagt ich kann jetzt ohne
test zum friseur ich darf länger raus in
der sperrstunde sozusagen wie nehmen sie
das wahr
nein das überzeugt mich noch nicht
einsatz zu norbert walter borjans zuvor
der auf die 165 er incidents bei den
schulen ja abgehoben hat das sei nur die
bundes notbremse länder könnten ja
schärfer vorgehen ich habe ja folgenden
kritikpunkt ich glaube dass man über
maßnahmen des logins erst dann
nachdenken sollte wenn alle anderen
möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft sind und ich
sehe dass offen gestanden noch nicht wir
haben eben über textbasierte konzepte
oder ins basierte konzepte gesprochen
wir haben noch nicht überall die
konsequente masken pflicht gehabt wir
haben vor allen dingen noch nicht die
gegenwärtig besonders betroffenen
gruppen blick genommen wir müssen noch
zur kenntnis nehmen dass das pandemie
geschehen insbesondere in den
großstädten sich in bestimmten
stadtteilen gegenwärtig konzentriert wo
wir besonders prekäre problemlagen haben
ja gut aber wenn sie das sagen dann
bedeutet das doch dass die reine ins
tendenz zahl allein wenn der wissen in
bestimmten stadtteilen sind die probleme
besonders gewalt das darf doch gar keine
rolle mehr spielen das muss auch viel
differenzierter betrachtet werden jetzt
zu ihrem punkt herrnsheimer erster punkt
zu ihrem aspekt erster gedanke wir
hätten schon beim beschluss des neuen
infektionsschutzgesetzes regeln treffen
müssen jetzt geht auch wieder zeit ins
land jetzt kommt erst die
rechtsverordnung dann muss der bundestag
bundesrat zustimmen da geht doch zeit
ins land wir hatten an änderungsantrag
gemacht dass im gesetz zu regeln ist er
längst geklärt war nicht gewollt warum
da können wir motivforschung machen
zweiter punkt es muss test und ins
basierte öffnungs konzepte für alle
geben also insbesondere für die jungen
menschen die noch länger auf eine
impfung warten müssen und dann drittens
herbolzheimer wer geimpft ist zum
zweiten mal wo wartezeit verstrichen ist
von dem also keine gefahr für andere
ausgeht und der selbst nichts gefährdet
ist da verbietet sich jede form der
freiheitseinschränkung das bedeutet dass
dann auch ab sofort zum beispiel sollte
derjenige in restaurants gehen können
ins kino gehen können
das bedeutet dass ich bin dann dafür
dass diese menschen mit ihrem
aber nicht digitalen sondern gelben
impfpass ins restaurant gehen und wissen
sie was dem lungenkranken oder oder dem
79-jährigen dem gönne ich dass ich bin
zur stunde noch nicht geimpft ich gönne
es ihm
denn mein lieblings italiener muss
wieder umsatz machen weil sonst gibt es
im demnächst auch für mich gar nichts
mehr und die menschen lassen sie uns die
wahrheit aussprechen
die hoch betagt sind und jetzt schon
geimpft sind
die haben natürlich auch eine andere
lebensspanne noch vor sich als ein
22-jähriger und deshalb wiegt die
einschränkung der betätigung im
öffentlichen leben für die er auch viel
schwerer als ziemlich mit 42 oder für
einen 22-jährigen und deshalb wer
geimpft ist soll seine freiheit wieder
bekommen das ist eine eine das sollte
uns stolz machen dass da wieder leben
möglich ist das sollte kein anlass für
knight sang er blumen sind sie da dabei
kämpfte wieder ins restaurant aufmachen
für diejenigen die geimpft sind keine
zeit verlieren ich halte es
grundsätzlich für den richtigen weg denn
die beschränkungen die wir alle mit uns
wie wir alle auf uns genommen haben
die wir staat verordnet hat die sind nur
so lange zu rechtfertigen wie es eben
kein impfangebot gibt und in den teilen
wurde das impfangebot heute schon
wahrgenommen werden konnte
da muss doch dann auch klar sein dass
ich dort erstes das was schon der
gesunde menschenverstand einem sagt
umsätze nämlich jemand der doppelt
geimpft ist der muss nicht extra noch
ein test ergebnis vorlegen weil impfen
besser ist als jeder test und natürlich
ist der nächste schritt und auch darüber
werden wir jetzt in der kommenden woche
reden welche weitergehenden schritte
dann denkbar sind aber was sagen
restaurants auch für geimpfte lasse
nämlich das gut sagen es kann kein
anlass möchte ich als wenn jemand der
jetzt geimpft ist das ja ich beantworte
es ja es kann keinen anspruch geben von
jemand der geimpft ist das jetzt das
öffentliche heimat sozusagen wieder
aufmacht aber ich bin mir sicher dass
wir wenn wir über öffnung der
außengastronomie vielleicht im ersten
schritt reden oder öffnungen von
kultureinrichtungen das
selbstverständlich diejenigen die
geimpft sind das dann auch
contact konzepte denkbar sind wovon
denen diese einrichtungen dann ab
nächster woche biergarten außen in
bayern möglich für geimpfte es ist
leider noch saukalt in bayern ich sehe
das mit dem bier gab noch nicht aber
herr uns wenn man sich eingereicht damit
wir mal etwas nach bayern 1 und dann
sehen wir uns im biergarten
herr walter borjans sind sie dabei
außengastronomie auch für geimpfte
vielleicht sogar schon diese woche wenn
alles entschieden ist kann man da
konzepte fahren also wir sollten einfach
schlicht und ergreifend bei der wahrheit
und bei der ehrlichkeit bleiben dass wir
jetzt dabei sind erstmal festzulegen in
dieser kommenden woche dass diejenigen
die eine vollständige impfung haben und
das sind bislang erst um die zwölf
prozent wenn ich richtig liege also wir
sind ja was die doppelte impfung angeht
noch nicht so weit und sind jetzt gerade
dabei dass wir die erste impfung zahl
deutlich erhöhen
und deswegen sollten wir doch einfach
jetzt nicht die illusion erwecken dass
wir eben wie das eben dieser beitrag
auch gezeigt hat über den immer noch
nicht so ganz weg bin 300 und die dürfen
in die kneipe
das möchte ich nicht das muss man auch
ganz ehrlich sagen aber der beitrag
zeigt ja nur die realität die es in
europa gibt er war dabei schnell wie
möglich so schnell wie möglich öffnungen
freiheiten zurückgeben
er ist überhaupt keine frage ist macht
keiner aus spaß eine eine grenze die
einen gastwirten zwingt aber sie machen
ja keine konkrete ansage hier sie sagen
ja nicht wann sie bereit sind dafür dann
es geht darum dass wir jetzt erstmal
eine festgelegte zahl haben die die
notbremse beschreibt und die die länder
jeweils und da bin ich im übrigen
absolut föderalist ich gehöre nicht zu
denen die immer sofort nach dem staat
rufen und dem einen der das stark durch
regiert sondern ich finde richtig dass
in unterschiedlichen ländern auf die
regionalen besonderheiten eingegangen
werden kann und wir sind jetzt dabei das
wir impfen das hat der blumen ja auch
angesprochen das stand ja auch überhaupt
nicht außer frage dass jemand der gegen
ried ist nicht zusätzlich noch getestet
werden muss
das kommt jetzt um den werden nach und
nach alle möglichkeiten die wir hatten
bevor wir von dieser furchtbaren
pandemie heimgesucht worden sind wieder
geöffnet aber das kann man nicht sagen
nächste woche ist die außengastronomie
wieder offen
das ist mir schon anliegen weil norbert
walter baur vorsitzender der spd ist
also einer partei die in der regel nicht
in den villen vororten gewählt wird die
hunderter incidents bei der notbremse
bedeutet dass insbesondere in den
großstädten in denen in den stadtteilen
auch wo die menschen im hochhaus wohnen
ohne balkon in kleinem raum mit ihren
kindern dass dort alle
freiheitseinschränkung weiter bleiben
herr walter borjans ist ihnen eigentlich
nur eins was ihre harte haltung bei der
hunderter inzidenz mit der
undifferenzierte damit verbunden ist für
eine enorme soziale problematik ist erst
mal bewusst lieber herr lewis bereich
darf ich mal kurz das genau in diesen
bereichen in diesen stadtteilen wir
dafür sorgen müssen dass jetzt auch
schnell mit mobilen einrichtungen
geimpft werden kann sie kennen selbst
die stadt köln sie kennen selbst einen
vorort in dem sich alle wurden durften
der hat eine instanz von null und es
gibt einen anderen stadtteil der hat
neben rund 500 und ich kann nicht ich
kann nicht das problem dadurch lösen
dass ich in dem stadtteil in dem die
inzidenz 500 ich sage ja dann noch mal
alles auf sondern was ich machen kann
ist sich dass ich dafür sorge dass wir
in den nächsten schritten uns angucken
müssen dass da wo das problem am größten
ist die menschen auch die chance
bekommen geimpft zu werden und nicht nur
dann wenn sie da auch ein arzt
persönlich kennen das ist eine ganz
wichtige größe daran müssen wir arbeiten
und genau das hat das haben sie richtig
beschrieben dass ich mich dafür
verantwortlich fühle dass wir in diesen
stadtteilen sehr schnell die gefahr
begrenzen weil das insgesamt das leben
in der stadt natürlich in den schulen in
den betrieben auch belastet und deswegen
haben wir an der stelle eben auch ein
schwerpunkt ist er absolut recht
aber daher walter borjans ja gerade
gesagt hat ich hätte mal in köln
gewohnt habe ich nie will ich sagen ich
habe in düsseldorf bilk und
industriearbeiter stadtteil und jetzt
wollte ich in berlin schöneberg und
jetzt dessen handy das mit bedauern
zurück aber es gibt diesen stadtteilen
noten wo wohnen sie
wo wohnen sie
ich wohne ja quasi innenstadt also das
ist das ist jedenfalls nicht
ich sag mal kann kein besonders
bevorzugter stadtteil in dem
zusammenhang herr walter borjans unter
lindner wird auch immer wieder die
debatte geführt inwieweit ein
migrationshintergrund eine rolle spielt
bei der frage zum beispiel was das
schnelle impfen angeht aber auch bei der
frage wie hoch infektionszahlen sind ist
das ein tabu thema her kellner schon sie
soll an da werden sie feststellen dass
das eine frage die mit allem
zusammenhängt deswegen sehen wir dass
die dass die werte so unterschiedlich
sind und es ist nicht eine frage beim
migrationshintergrund seien es ist eine
frage von armutsgefährdung natürlich den
menschen die auf engerem raum zusammen
wohnen deutlich gefährdet haben wo der
abstand geringer ist und das ist
überhaupt kein tabu mehr sollte man
nicht so tun als wenn es jetzt die
migrantinnen und migranten schuld
sondern soziale frage und lassen sich
auch noch etwas sagen zu der ganzen
debatte jetzt ging ja meditieren
ehrliche welche grundrechte reden gerät
zurückgeben ich bin zum beispiel ist die
im lichte menschen ist doch klar sein
muss sie müssen nicht in quarantäne
wenn sie eine k1 person treffen also
eine person die sozusagen selber
infektiös ist und dann zwei wochen in
quarantäne
nein münchen nicht mehr das ist das ist
eine freiheitseinschränkung die sollte
man zurück nämlich möchte aber noch was
zu italienern und zu den biergärten
sagen da sitzen ja nicht nur an die
menschen die die rechnung bezahlen da
sind ja auch die menschen die die
rechnungen bringen die das bier füllen
die die pizza backen
wer also alles auch das heißt wenn es um
freiheit geht dann ist es geht es auch
darum dass wir allen fünf angebote geben
dass du deswegen müssen wir das so
schenken damit nämlich auch diejenigen
die nicht über italiener sitzen sondern
auch bedienen
das alte chance haben sich impfen zu
lassen und dann können wir dann auch
noch die freiheits räume für alle
vergrößern herr blume ich möchte doch
noch ganz kurz bei der frage bleiben der
debatte um den migrationshintergrund das
war auch thema zum beispiel im
cdu-präsidium anfang vergangener woche
wo ihren spaß gesagt hat dass das eine
herausforderung ist zum beispiel
migranten von einer impfung zu
überzeugen und wenn man sich statistiken
anschaut
darauf hat ja auch der lkw chef
verwiesen der hat das als tabuthema
einmal bezeichnet wie sie nehmen sie das
war also das phänomen was jetzt hier
beschrieben wird das gibt es natürlich
und da darf man auch gar nicht um den
heißen brei herum reden man muss nur die
richtigen schlussfolgerungen ziehen
das was christian lindner gesagt hat
dass deswegen der inzidenz ansatz falsch
wäre das sehe ich nicht aber ein anderer
ansatz der ist zunehmend falsch nämlich
der ansatz der impf priorisierung das
heißt wenn wir schon sehen dass es hier
stadtteile gibt oder bevölkerungsgruppen
gibt für die ein niederschwelliges ins
impfangebot extrem wichtig ist dann
sollten wir diesen niederschwelligen
impfangebot auch den weg ebnen und
deswegen sind wir der meinung dass wir
so schnell wie möglich wenn wir jetzt
die impf gruppe 3 hinter uns lassen dass
wir wirklich dieses impfen für alle
schaffen das dann auch wirklich die
möglichkeit besteht strategischer zu
impfen in betriebe reinzugehen in
stadtteile reinzugehen familien durch zu
impfen
das muss jetzt der nächste schritt sein
und wir müssen schauen dass hier nicht
dann wieder die im bürokratie zuschlägt
geschwindigkeit an dieser stelle ist
absolut entscheidend ab wann dürfen denn
aus ihrer sicht blume geimpfte was genau
tun denn das habe ich immer noch nicht
verstanden welchen zeitplan sie da haben
wann darf ich genau was
die beratungen laufen jetzt in der
kommenden woche wenn alles gut geht dann
kann das auch dem die verschiedenen
gremien der bundesregierung bundesrat in
dieser woche passieren
ihr habt es waren ja schon gesagt ich
bin froh dass wir jetzt damit hochdruck
diesen ersten großen schritt auch gehen
können
er war der borjans wenn sie die debatte
hier um das impfen und auch die debatte
die bei ihren ministerpräsidenten l
geführt wird verfolgen warum scheint es
so dass gerade die spd so ein gegner
davon ist schnell grundrechte
zurückzugeben oder zumindest die
ministerpräsidenten die sich dort so in
der sitzung geäußert haben also es
scheint es ist ein falscher schein weil
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten und das erlebe ich
nun wirklich in vielen gesprächsrunden
die wir miteinander haben sich hier
nicht gegenseitig hochpushen damit dass
sie freiheiten nicht gewähren wollen
sondern dass die verantwortung
übernehmen und wir alle haben das doch
in es ist doch nicht eine frage von von
spd oder cdu schroeder hat sich doch nun
wirklich lange genug 100 damit
hervorgetan
immer diese ganz harten regeln zu
fordern und wir haben immer wieder
gesagt wie wichtig an vielen stellen es
ist das gerade zb bei kindern und
jugendlichen die die folgen die dadurch
entstehen dass man zu hause eingesperrt
ist praktisch dass wir die nicht nicht
akzeptieren können und dass wir deswegen
nach öffnungs strategien suchen und
deswegen noch mal ich glaube wir haben
alle gemeinsam
doch einen blick darauf dass jeder doch
überzeugt davon ist auch besonders die
situation im eigenen land gut zu kennen
ich bin nun mal hier in nordrhein
westfalen ich lebe gern in diesem land
hier regiert jetzt eine andere regierung
mit beteiligung von der laschet und und
herrn winters parteien und die sehen
auch wie unterschiedlich die situation
im land gerade in einem land mit
unglaublich vielen großstädten ist und
das ist doch eine andere situation als
sie sich im saarland oder in mecklenburg
vorpommern
schleswig-holstein ereignet und deswegen
finde ich es richtig dass jeweils nach
den besonderheiten und den gegebenheiten
im land nach regeln gesucht wird um hier
gemeinsam am ende für das gesamte land
die pandemie am besten in den griff zu
kriegen also wir hatten fest beim thema
impfungen beim thema der frage wann
geimpft die rechte zurückbekommen und
wie sie aussehen soll es nächste woche
klarheit geben zumindest markus blume
und christian lindner sind sich da einig
dass dann vielleicht auch schnell die
außengastronomie aufmachen könnte auch
herr keller forderte einen schnellen
zugang zum abschluss in den letzten zehn
minuten unserer sendungen möchte ich
jetzt noch einmal auf zwei weitere
themen kommen die die nächste woche
wichtig werden und zwar das thema klima
her kellner
da haben heute ihre da wurde heute ein
brief an die kanzlerin angela merkel und
scholz versand und daraufhin hat sich
thomas bareiß direkt eingeschaltet der
staatssekretär und hat gesagt was die
grünen hier fordern ist sozialpolitisch
unanständig co2 co2 preis von 25 auf 60
das heißt vor allem dass berufspendler
und eigentümer kleiner einfamilienhäuser
eine jährliche mehrbelastung von 325
euro aufkommen müssen wie gehen sie auch
vor dem hintergrund der frage dass sie
ja mit der union vielleicht mal zusammen
regieren wollen jetzt in diese
klimawoche nun herr bahr es ist ein
gutes beispiel darum warum die große
koalition so eine klatsche beim
bundesverfassungsgericht gekommen hat
wichtig ist dass jetzt das politik
handelt dass wir nicht nur die
zielzahlen erhöhen bis wann wieder co2
einsparen sondern auch konkrete
maßnahmen ergreifen
deswegen fordern wir ein kohleausstieg
auch 2030 vor 10 höhere co2 preis den
wir übrigens ausschütten wollen
das heißt menschen die wenig verbrauchen
kriegen genauso viel zurück wie alle
anderen profitieren damit wird
durchschnittlich also das hat eine
soziale ausgleich wirkung und ehrlicher
brauchen einen schnelleren ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien in diesem land da
ist viel verschlafen worden und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn diese
regierung danach handeln würde was
gehabt standhalten aber was bedeutet das
ganz konkret für den verbraucher für den
einzelnen wie hoch werden die
mehrbelastung was bedeutet das zum
beispiel für die frage wie viel fleisch
jemand künftig essen soll was ist mit
diesel autos also was bedeuten die dinge
die sie vorhaben jetzt auch vor dem
hintergrund dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat und
vor dem hintergrund der des wahlkampfs
für den einzelnen
das bedeutet einmal dass wir massiv und
schleunigst erneuerbare energien
ausbauen müssen damit wir den
kohleausstieg auch 2030 vollziehen kann
das ganze ist wenn das nicht so an die
wand gefahren wäre dann sehen wir dass
erneuerbare schon heute deutlich
preisgünstiger sind als fossile energie
das heißt wir können da kleinkinder geld
sparen und wir sagen mit dem c02 ist
über science hat mit lenkungswirkung so
ein co2 preis und da wollen wir sozialen
ausgleich reinnehmen das heißt
bestückten g co2 pro kopf pro person aus
so dass menschen die wenig energie
verbrauchen was heißt das konkret der
kellner das versteht ja der zuschauer
nicht was es für den einzelnen bedeutet
also wie hoch wird die mehrbelastung ja
wir reden wir reden insgesamt bei einem
bei einem co2 preis von 35 auf knapp 60
60 euro reden wir von jährlichen auch
ein paar euro bereichen sowohl bei der
frage von 1 energie als auch bei der
frage von den kosten und deswegen ist
also wie viel euro
wie viel euro ja es ist das ist nicht
das da denkt man immer ist es so
wahnsinnig viel aber ehrlich gesagt
durch den umstieg durch den umstieg auf
aber nennen wir da mal einen preis kann
email also wenn melden sie sich
anschauen was es kostet dann sind wir
bei da sind wir ungefähr bei eigentlich
davon ab wie viel sie diesen enden bei
150 euro umgebaut
im jahr herr lindner was glauben sie
kommt da auf die deutschen zu was sind
ihre rechnungen die sie bei der fdp
machen nicht bei der fdp sondern es hier
immer gerade spontan und wir alle
gemeinsam können dass man auf
plausibilität testen
der deutsche verbraucht im durchschnitt
elf tonnen co2 pro person
jetzt hat der kellner gerade
vorgeschlagen das von 25 euro das ist
der co2 tonnenpreis zu beginn dieses
jahres ist er eingeführt worden
übrigens mit zustimmung der grünen also
der co2 preis von 25 euro der seit
januar dieses jahres gilt der er ist
erreicht worden durch verhandlungen der
grünen also das jetzige kohle ausstiegs
gesetz gibt es nur weil die grünen mit
verhandelt haben ist also das gesetz der
grünen auch das im karl poppers machen
zehn euro die große koalition vorschlag
hat und wir haben dann im bundesrat in
der tat gesorgt dass überhaupt mal
effekt 825 euro
was ist schon damals nicht mal alles wie
bisher weiter auf 35 euro und mir sagen
ja auch 60 euro das wissen sie ja ja
nehmen wir nehmen wir zu protokoll wenn
ich sehe ist er anfang des jahres auf 25
euro eingeführt worden und saß bereits
recht 1035 sowohl auf 60 auf 60 erhöhen
nur rechnungen ich bis gar nicht
bewerten 35 euro mehr pro tonne mal elf
tonnen zeigen sie uns mal einen
taschenrechner herr länder wie sieht der
aus nur damit wir den sehen können sehr
gut was brauchen so das sind 385 euro
pro person nehmen wir eine vierköpfige
familie sind das 1540 euro pro person
die die grünen jetzt vorschlagen bei 25
auf 60 tonnen co2 pro tonne
man merkt auf jeden fall dieses mal
nachts minister werden wollten hellen
sagen sie jetzt auf dem rücken dürften
sie bekommen so dass es zu mehr und als
derjenige der ein kleinwagen hat und in
den klassen den punkt zu ende machen
erkenne sie können dort danach sofort
eingreifen ich habe das jetzt
sachlich dargestellt dass ich das
unterscheidet gehabt weniger als etwas
mehr als elfter
ob ich sollte sich dass sie nicht in der
lage sind meine gedanken jetzt kurz
anzuhören wissen sie ich habe dann
versucht es zu ergänzen was sie gerne
vergessen wollten oder das würde doch
häufig und gern das hat auch einen tisch
weiter
die sind daran erinnern in ihren
ausführungen ja dann machen sie es jetzt
gern ich bin höflich aber moment herr
lindner jetzt wollen wir erst mal ihre
rechnung war dass der abschluss betrag
den sie da erreicht das daran dass war
der abschluss betrag nur allein und
deutlich zu machen die erhöhung und
jetzt kommt meine kritik wir haben jetzt
wirklich gerechnet wären ja wir wollen
das geld ja auch zurückgeben wir wollen
um verteilen und so weiter es soll ja
dann bei der vierköpfigen familien mit
geringem einkommen gar nicht so hart
sein weil wir nehmen da war es weg und
dann gehen wir das zurück und verteilen
um also eine gigantische
umverteilungsmaschine ich mache anderen
vorschlag wenn das überzeugt was der
kenner darstellen wird gleich der kann
das ja machen ja auch viele wählen super
demokratie ich machen anderen vorschlag
mein vorschlag ist wir wechseln aber ein
anderes modell wir steuern nicht mehr
mit dem preis weil das hat sich in den
letzten 25 jahren nicht als erfolgreich
herausgestellt
ältere erinnern sie an die ökosteuer die
eingeführt worden ist noch von hans
eichel glaube ich da hat man das benzin
teurer gemacht daran geglaubt hat die
leute fahren mehr und haben fahren
weniger und haben weniger autos nicht
der fall haben nicht funktioniert die
leute haben nur gibt mir geblecht er
sagt jetzt mein vorschlag wir machen ein
altes co2 limit es gibt einfach nicht
mehr co2 auszustoßen gibt es nicht und
wer es mehr etwas davon braucht von
diesem budget muss sich an anteil kaufen
was ist der vorteil einer solchen
mengensteuerung sagen die experten
es entsteht ein enormer
innovationswettbewerb um die vermeidung
von co2 und auf jeden fall ist eins
gesichert nämlich die erreichung von co2
vermeidung ziehen
herr blume schüttelte mit dem kopf der
will mit dem kellner gemeinsam lieber
die verbrennungsmotoren verbieten
dann ist auch erlaubt ich glaube nur
nicht er steht auf der blume steht auf
der seite der marktwirtschaft
emissionshandel schon gezeigt
herr blume was macht die csu mit also
wie viele bäume wollen sie umarmen und
mit den grünen in die koalition dann zu
gehen und wie weit sind sie bereit
mitzumachen und bis zu welchem preis
also dass der christian lindner als
vertreter der fdp jetzt plötzlich der
mengensteuerung das wort rede das kennt
man früher aus der ddr oder rassismus
ich glaube das ist ich glaube das ist
nicht der richtige weg
wir glauben daran dass preisbildung
entscheidend ist und sehr christian
lindner weiß ja auch dass das
eigentliche ziel beim co2 handel ist
dass wir eine freie preisbildung
bekommen
es ist politisch notwendig dass wir
einen einstieg finden wir sind
eingestiegen mit 25 euro und glaube es
ist schon wichtig dass wir stärkere
preissignale haben aber auch der anderen
seite und das ist meine kritik an dem
konzept der grünen michael kellner dass
wir jetzt hier nicht die große öko
staatliche umverteilungsmaschinerie dann
im gang werfen sondern dass wir von
vornherein wenn wir hier etwas machen
sicherstellen dass auf der anderen seite
auch entlastung gibt und zwar in
denselben systeme die wirken das heißt
wir müssen die stromsteuer uns anschauen
wir müssen uns die eeg-umlage anschaue
wie teuer wird es für den ein und wenn
ich auf der einen seite einen höheren
wie teuer wird es für den 1 wenn ich
also das kann ich ihnen jetzt heute
abend hier am sonntag nicht sagen haben
keine dabei aber unterm strich und ich
habe dabei aber die funktionalität die
funktionalität reicht da jetzt nicht aus
ich glaube das ist etwas ganz anderes
und anfragen norbert walter borjans
weiter bis zu welchem preis sind sie
bereit damit zu machen und vor allem wie
schwierig das dann also erst mal finde
ich bei dem ansatz von herrn kellner
richtig dass dahinter die feste
verabredung stehen muss dass die
einnahmen die aus der co2 steuer kommen
zurückgegeben werden und damit ein
anreiz geschaffen wird wer sich ändert
wer weniger co2 produziert hat einen
überschuss der bekommt mehr als er
zusätzlich zahlen muss und die anderen
müssen mehr bezahlen
so jetzt müssen wir vielleicht mal mal
erlebt man das immer so sagt das ist so
plausibel
sagt dann was im durchschnitt pro bürger
mit elf tonnen an co2 anfällt wir
sollten vielleicht erst mal festhalten
dass 90 prozent der bürger für 50
prozent des co2 ausstoßes zuständig sind
und die oberen die bessergestellten zehn
prozent für die anderen 50 prozent dh
wenn ich das modell mache dass ich das
was wir auch gefordert haben und jetzt
auch in unserem zukunftsprogramm stehen
haben nämlich darüber nachdenken es
zurückzugeben im über einen bonus an die
bürger dann würde das für 90 prozent der
bevölkerung bedeuten dass die keinen
mehraufwand haben wenn sie sich nicht
ändern aber etwas gewinnen wenn sie
weniger co2 verbrauchen also wenn sie
auf öffentliche verkehrsmittel umsteigen
wo immer das möglich ist wenn es nicht
möglich ist wird es auch nicht teurer
aber die anderen jetzt sag jetzt mal die
generation svw für den kindergarten
die haben dann einen zusatzaufwand und
sollten sich eben auch überlegen ob sie
das nicht einsparen können die
generation suv willst dann musst du dann
mehr zahlen wie viel muss sie dann mehr
zahlen
wir leben noch weitermachen will na ja
das hat es aber ausgerechnet also wenn
wenn wenn das 30 euro pro tonne sind
dann muss man ausrechnen wie viel ist
das jetzt in bezug auf diesen teil der
bevölkerung aber doch nur wenn es keine
verhaltens veränderung gibt das ist doch
genau der anreiz und deswegen finde ich
so interessant was herr lindner sagte
das erst über eine mengensteuerung
machen möchte wenn ich die menge
begrenzen
also sie wollen diejenigen bestrafen die
das falsche automatisch er unterstellt
ja so automatisch dann werden die
erfinder wach und dann wird alles
erfunden aber sie als wie wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden dass wir wollen
weniger co2 das aber nichts es wird
teurer wenn ich so nie verstanden habe
er war der orientalist zurückgehen
wollen sie diejenigen dann bestrafen die
aus ihrer sicht das falsche verhalten an
den tag legen so haben sie es ja gerade
formuliert das heißt bestrafen es geht
darum dass wir co2 einsparen müssen das
ist ein das ist ein spruch der
verfassungsrichter wir müssen runter
das wird mit sicherheit als als als
fester block eingeschlagen werden müssen
und deshalb das hat nichts mit
bestrafung zu tun wir müssen aber
irgendwie und es soll belohnt werden
werden wer sich dann
so verhält das ist weniger wird ja wir
wollen verhaltens veränderung wir müssen
sie ja haben aber wo bekommt man da das
ist ja die gleichen ausschuss wo beginnt
man da und wo hört man auf mehr war der
ball also man kann jetzt sagen okay der
fährten der suv mensch dass es böse der
verbrauch zu gehen muss aber kann man
daraus auch ein suv
na ja sie haben ja gerade von der
generation gesprochen das ist jetzt ja
nicht mein ding
aber was ist dann bei denen viele erst
das wie ist auch mit elektromotoren
fahren ja aber was ist denn dann bei
demjenigen der das fleisch ist das was
ist mit demjenigen der der zu oft zum
beispiel sich sich fleisch bestellt oder
einkauft muss der dann nicht auf die
strafen sagen jetzt als sie verwenden
jetzt den begriff des zu oft es geht um
die frage wie wir insgesamt das budget
an co2 dass wir zuviel ausstoßen mit dem
wir deutlich und deutlich ja noch runter
müssen was wir auch gerne gehabt hätten
das hat der koalitionspartner nicht
mitgetragen das wird uns jetzt von den
verfassungsrichtern vorgegeben dann
müssen wir runter und in welcher
mischung wir das hinbekommen ob ich
weniger autofahrer weniger fleisch esse
was auch immer das ist die ist die eine
frage aber es geht wissen dass wir
dieses ziel erreichen müssen
ich glaube den menschen sprechen es darf
nur nicht dazu führen dass jemand der
wenig verdient sich das alles nicht mehr
leisten kann und andere sagen ich zahle
das aus der portokasse und nach finder
bisher wären da bin ich jetzt
ausnahmsweise mal einer meinung mit
norbert walter borjans oder nicht
ausnahmsweise es gibt auch andere punkte
wie bei einer meinung sind aber in
diesem korridor genau ist ja vielleicht
auch gut weil das ist ja genau die idee
dessen was ich eben co2 limit genannt
habe bei der reinen preis steuerung bei
ihrem es jogi beispiel norbert walter
borjans da können die leute die geld
haben einfach weitermachen wie bisher
wenn man die co2 menge strikt begrenzt
dann wird das nicht gehen dann haben wir
automatisch an entlastungs fahrt und wir
müssen bitte sehen generation suv das
ist so ein klein bisschen klischee was
damit spielt was ist denn mit der
älteren frau aber bewusst dass man sie
von autor länder werden sie bestraft
wenn sie wenn das kommt
ich werde nicht bestraft weil ich habe
an wasserstoff fcl mercedes der ist
batterieelektrischen wasserstoff
elektrisch also ich bin raus herr blume
muss müssen wir angst und sie haben oder
was fun sie ich bin übrigens co2 neutral
ich lasse meine einem bayerisch diesel
fabrikat aber aber das ist schon fertig
da müssen sie dann schon also wenn sie
jetzt dann in die koalition wollen mit
den grünen vielleicht als juniorpartner
dann wird schon gefährlich oder
herrnsheimer dürfen wir einfach noch
ernsthaft sagen sie brauchen sie sie
brauchen sich keine sorgen machen uns ja
weil ich bin noch eben auf den punkt
hinaus weil die sozialen fragen sind
enorm bedeutsam für die akzeptanz und
generation suv erweckt den eindruck
jüngere leute hohes einkommen fahren mit
ihrem q5 den den der da produziert wird
aber was ist er mit der älteren dame die
hat mit kleine rente hat ein haus das
sie alleine bewohnt weiß ich schon 30
jahre drin enormer bedarf in
energetischer gebäudesanierung und
uralten heizung
das ist doch die frage was machen wir
mit dieser dame dass du da nicht
ausziehen verkaufen muss und so weiter
da ist die problematik da kann man nicht
einfach sagen höherer co2 preis und wir
geben dem woanders zurück die hat ja
nicht sondern erst zu anders zurückgeben
kann die zahl auch keine steuern mehr
zumindest nur sehr wenig auf ihre rente
und die fragen müssen noch geklärt so
stoller sprengstoff und er sagt ist mein
vorschlag ganz konkret es wird die
regierung im schnellschuss machen
altmaier und frau schulze wird man sich
ansehen wenn das klappt dann sind wir
auch dabei und konstruktiv im bundesrat
und bundestag alles klar ich glaube das
wird in den mühlen des wahlkampfs
spätestens von den grünen zerrieben
werden aber ich mag nicht täuschen mein
vorschlag ist ein anderer rechnen schon
wieder oder da gucken so oft ich rechne
nicht ich rechne nicht mein vorschlag
ist herr ronzheimer und sagen auch den
kollegen es müssten sich eigentlich alle
parteien im grunde sind das die vier
hier die im zentrum des demokratischen
prozesses stehen die müssten sich
zusammenfinden zu einem nationalen klima
konnten
der muss nämlich länger halten als eine
legislaturperiode es ist doch völlig
klar wenn die große koalition jetzt
irgendwas wieder beschließt der kellner
hat hört schon gesagt ja das was im
januar beschlossen worden ist oder in
kraft getreten ist das war ja nur
kompromiss wir wollen sowieso
draufsatteln
dann lasst uns diese gespräche doch
bereits jetzt führen nationaler klima
konsens der länger hält als eine
legislaturperiode oder gar nur ein paar
wochen
er kenne also ich freue mich darüber
alles was die bundesregierung übernimmt
ja und und macht noch vor der
bundestagswahl findet total super und da
auch gerne mit den stimmen der fdp
finde ich super da bin ich es ist so
dringlich dass wir dass wir vorankommen
und ehrlich gesagt ja ich befürchte ist
es nicht ausreichend wird und dass wir
auch nächstes jahr und auch ende des
jahres weitere maßnahmen für den
klimaschutz ergreifen müssen und dass
wir da mal soziale auswirkungen klicken
wir müssen das ist richtig deswegen
sollte jeder auch mit einem bonussystem
rückzahlungen bekommen so dass er sie
nicht belastet erst sagen seine frau im
häuschen die herr lindner gerade so
eindrücklich beschrieben hat dass sie
nicht ausziehen musste sie geholfen wird
bei der nachrüstung der will heizung
dass sie eine rückzahlung bekommt für
das weil die frau verbraucht relativ
wenig energie im vergleich zu dem
stadtteil beuel als erfolg gerade sehr
schön geschrieben wer verbraucht was das
ist diese frau sein und deshalb sind sie
dabei bei dem konvent den herr lindner
vorgeschlagen hat bei einem konvent
nicht glauben konnte team einen konsens
ich glaube dass der weg weit ist
zwischen dem was die fdp zum thema
klimaschutz sagt und dem was wir sagen
ja wir haben die bundestagswahl und die
bringen wir jetzt sachen schon vorher
auf dem weg kriegen freue ich mich total
weil ich sagt die klimakrise warten
nicht darauf denn dann machen wir mal
die probe das haben wir schon mal bei
einem thema gemacht erkenne sie kennen
das einmal bitte ganz kurz hand heben
werden für diesen klima konsens zu haben
ist ich bin für
für alles zu haben sich gar jetzt bin
ich sehr verwirrt ich habe gerade gesagt
wir sind alle vielleicht sollten wir
nochmal reden darüber herunter was jetzt
nicht das ziel also ich glaube und auch
gerne noch notwendig ist nutzen
notwendig sind notwendig sind drei dinge
das erste ist wir brauchen eine größere
steuerungswirkung über den co2 preis
wenn sie konkret fragen von 25 euro
die 60 euro erscheinen mir von den
grünen deutlich zu viel aber vielleicht
ist es gut sich in der mitte zu treffen
dann wären wir irgendwo vielleicht bei
45 euro das zweite ist wir müssen
beschleunigen die der investitionen auch
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
investitionen in infrastruktur und das
dritte ist wir sollten aber auch andere
absurditäten dann auch wieder lassen
also habe ich vorhin schon wieder gehört
die ganze fleisch diskussion lassen uns
wirklich auf die großen wichtigen hebel
konzentrieren
aber jetzt nicht den deutschen das
fleisch madig machen weiter bogen
konsens könnten sie sich hier einigen am
ende erst mal auf denen das jetzt durch
die verfassungsrichter die regierung
gefordert ist nachzubessern und wir sind
froh dass die richter einen spruch
gesprochen haben der ein stück den
widerstand knackt den bisher vor allen
dingen der bundeswirtschaftsminister
geleistet hat und wir werden sehr
schnell 45 euro kann er war dabei als
umweltministerin
die werden sehr schnell jetzt einen eine
weiterentwicklung auf der grundlage
dessen was wir eigentlich immer wollten
und was jetzt ermöglicht wird ich höre
aus der cdu/csu dass dazu auch eine
große bereitschaft gegeben ist vorlegen
dass wir jetzt die notwendigen werte
anpassen und das war natürlich auch
wieder kellner sagt über massen reden
werden und dann gehen wir auf eine wahl
zu und dann wird sich herausstellen
wofür die menschen die stimme geben und
wie wir den von den richtern
vorgegebenen spruch dann umsetzen und
ich glaube wirklich dass wir es falsch
machen würden und das muss ich einen
lindner sagen wenn wir jetzt wieder den
den leuten mit dem kleinen einkommen die
an
machen wir wollen gerade die
sozialdemokraten oder in diesem fall
auch die grünen denen mehr abnehmen im
gegenteil aber wie viel wollen sie hat
mir ein geben soll wie viel wollen sie
denn in ihren jetzt am ende nicht mehr
belastet wird gegebenenfalls aber durch
eine umstellung auch durch eine
unterstützung umstellung 40 euro 45 euro
bus verbraucher sind immer dabei ist
noch einmal klartext also wie viel pro
tonne sind sie denn bereit mitzumachen
also wir haben ja jetzt schon ein
anwachsen bis auf 55 euro es ist ja
nicht so die 25 sind ja nur in diesem
jahr geltend und die werden wahr
die werden wir vermutlich höher setzen
müssen es wird aber vor allen dingen
ausgegangen davon wie viel müssen runter
mit dem co2 ausstoß und welche maßnahmen
und welche welche folgen sind dafür die
richtigen und das sollten wir jetzt
nicht an den preis an dem co2 preise als
erstes ansetzen
nur wenn da angesetzt wird dann gilt für
uns ganz klar
dann darf das nicht zu einer
mehrbelastung allein und mittelverdiener
haushalte werden es kann nur so
ausgestaltet sein dass ein umstellen
umdenken zu ersparnissen führen wird ich
glaube dass das auch eine wirkung haben
wird
aber jetzt habe ich immer noch nicht
verstanden welchen preis sie bereit sind
mitzumachen die grünen fordern 60 was
sagen sie
wir sind jetzt dabei dass wir sagen wir
wollen erstmal wird werden darüber erst
mal streiten müssen wie wir also sie
wollen keine antwort darauf ankommen
müssen nein wir werden jetzt nicht über
die maßnahme als erstes reden sondern
dass die ziele festgelegt werden und
sich daraus die maßnahme ergeben und
nochmal die müssen sozial verträglich
sein und kleine und mittlere begonnen
und nicht bestrafen und sie werden auch
im oberen bereich bin ich sicher
entweder zu einer verhaltensänderung
führen oder eben zu einem er betrachte
dann bezahlt wird und das wird auf dauer
dann zu sehen ist ein opfer damit die
diese reduktion erreichen
ich glaube dass wir ich sag jetzt mal
mindestens um die 65 prozent runter
müssen gegenüber den 55 dies bisher sind
und da sehen wir schon dass die wir auch
da die die ziele auseinandergehen cdu
ist er bei 60 prozent die grünen bei 70
dass wir uns angucken müssen am ende
müssen wir die ziele einhalten die uns
die verfassungsrichter vorgegeben haben
und es ist doch gut dass sie das getan
suchen dank für diese spannende debatte
zum thema corona zum thema was wir mit
dem klima machen sollen herzlichen dank
norbert walter borjans markus blume
christian und tanzstudio das ist jetzt
ein dreck und dann gebe ich für die
spannende diskussion zu diesen beiden
wichtigen themen herzlichen dank
halb europa
[Musik]